I mean you're bringing birth back to
Xander cage I use 14 years in here we
are 15 years 15 years 15 years from the
date that we started filming the first
two blogs and what does it mean for you
to bring about oh it's so it's one of
those characters that I knew needed to
return and it's just a matter of
aligning the stars to make it a reality
one of the films that I promised to one
of the characters I promised to return
to early on in my facebook pioneer days
was then a cage and it feels good to
deliver on that promise and they're
testing you because there's some extreme
stunts that you're involved with there
are definitely some extreme stunts and
ah no injuries right no major injuries
but we are pushing the envelope in terms
of stunts and I also I've been playing
kind of deep stoic characters for so
long that I needed to play a character
that was a lot more light a lot more fun
irreverent and extreme and for me
there's something therapeutic about
playing a character that I'm always
laughing and always always enjoying
myself and you could see it and
everything that I do I mean I just last
week I was filming a scene with Sam
Jackson with a with a choir and I got
out there and you were so good I just
had too much fun for you it was it was a
moment that could only happen on a xxx
set it was a lot of fun
but it's it's representative of how much
fun we been having filming this movie
and you know some grades that you're
sharing all this on social media with
your fans why is that so important to
you I think well because I have a very
strong connection with my page on social
media
I rely heavily on their input and I take
pride in kind of revealing other aspects
or our being human that's one thing that
the page is allowed this outlet to be
human and that's very gratifying and
very fun so human that you tell us that
you take a nap after your stunts I mean
I could take Sunday's the Sun the stuck
work is so extreme that lunch isn't out
yeah there are those days you know what
I love about this film is that there's
so many strong women involve our
Canadian girl nina dobrev had she been
showing you around Canada Nina Dobrev
has been so amazing and she as you said
she is another one of the amazing cast
members in our movie our movie Nina's
been incredible and she plays she proves
that you can be both hot sexy and smart
and funny
at the same time
I mean there's so much I could say about
Toronto
I haven't it's funny the last time I
filmed a movie that I had this kind of
fun yeah I was filming in Toronto film
called the pacifier and it was also a
light experience this one's a little
intense because of the stunts yeah and
at times the subject matter and it's a
true action movie but in terms of fun oh
my god I haven't had this much fun in so
I was just watching you shoot a scene
right now and it looks like you're
having a lot of fun we good to see a
little bit of your skin but you're
you're witty because like this is
someone that you're introducing to the
American audience he's so cool to the
introducer to a whole new place Deepika
is is just another example of that
powerful cast and one of the things that
she represents because she was one of
the first people that we casted first
actors that we kind of went outside of
Hollywood yeah and as you've seen with
them with that other saga that I produce
fast and furious we've tried to keep
that that saga multicultural what we
wanted to do different here was make it
international so we didn't just want to
go to Hollywood casting we wanted to
open it up on a global scale and find
talent all over the world which is
represented in tippecanoe is
unbelievable as you've seen today Chris
whoo Donnie Yen Rory McCann Tony Jaa
Toni Collette and and Rudy Rose who were
from Australia I mean we've really
managed to Nicky yam and Miss Colombia
we've really a managed to broaden the
scope and Hollywood's perception of
casting